und bei mir im studio ist welt chef
julian reichelt er wird jetzt gleich den
österreichischen kanzler sebastian kurz
interview danke sie na ja liebe
zuschauerinnen und zuschauer wir sind
jetzt in wien verbunden mit einem der
hauptakteure dieser dramatischen und
spektakulären letzten vergangenen
stunden und tage und nächte vor allem in
brüssel bei uns zugeschaltet ist jetzt
live der österreichische bundeskanzler
sebastian kurz guten abend nach wien
sie haben für österreich massive rabatte
bei den eu beiträgen herausgehandelt
allerdings auf kosten des green deals da
sind jetzt nur noch zehn milliarden drin
statt vormals 40 milliarden
wie erklären sie das den grünen mit
denen die regieren ich muss ein bisschen
widersprechen
unsere rabatte wenn du dich das kosten
des gewinns sondern das ganze ist ein
gesamtes verhandlungsergebnis nur kann
starke lobby sierung für digitalisierung
für innovation und forschung an für
projekte wie erasmus und abriss aber es
gibt auch andere länder und für andere
budgetposten kämpfen wie zum beispiel
die kaution oder anderes die rabatte
gewähren uns deshalb einen anderen weil
wir ein netto zahler sind in der
europäischen union
wir sind bereit sein zu zahlen als wir
herausbekommen aber wir wollen einfach
nicht als unsere beitrag ins
unermessliche steigen und daher haben
wir uns zusammengetan und der gruppe der
sogenannten spaß aber in vier also
dänemark niederlande schweden und
österreich wir sind dann des gipfels
auch noch unterstützt worden von
finnland und hier eben auch die dressen
unserer steuerzahlerinnen und
steuerzahler zu wahren
und ja ich bin froh dass der rabatt für
österreich deutlich geworden ist wir
sind auch unter den top nettozahler in
der eu
insofern halte ich das für
gerechtfertigt hätten sie sich träumen
lassen dass sie die bundeskanzlerin
angela merkel mal davon energisch
abhalten müssen deutsches geld
auszugeben
das weiß ich nicht
zumindest
sagen wir mal so verständnis dafür dass
die deutsche kanzlerin
für europa ist kalorie fand zustand
bringen wollte
ich habe auch grundsätzlich ihren zugang
unterstützt dass man so ein recovery
fand auf die beine stellt ich rechne er
auch noch an das wenn du einen vorschlag
alleine gemacht hätte dann wäre die
wahrscheinlich deutlich höher gewesen
als die 500 milliarden also es war schon
angela merkel ich auch lange zeit
versucht habe das wenn es schon
zuschüsse gibt dass diese zumindest
nicht ins unermessliche steigen
und ja wir waren dann ein wechsel bei
den verhandlungen jetzt in den letzten
tagen auf unterschiedlichen seiten
das gehört auch dazu aber am ende des
tages glaube ich ist ein guter
kompromiss rausgekommen
zum einen kann ich nachvollziehen warum
sieht ist in kairo rief und kreiert hat
weil sie natürlich wichtig ist dass wir
den wirtschaftlichen wiederaufbau auch
in schwächeren wirtschaftlich
schwächeren staaten unterstützten als
österreich oder deutschland
was wichtig ist auch staaten die schon
vor der krise überschuldet waren jetzt
unterstützen dass die situation nicht
noch dramatischer wird aber umgekehrt
sollte jetzt glaube ich hat es auch
deutschland nicht schadet setzt die
sparsamen länder gegeben hat und nur
österreichische schwedisches steuergeld
spaß haben sondern indirekt auch man es
möchte deutschen steuerzahler einen
feind gemacht haben das waren ja lange
lange nächte lange stunden da in brüssel
man einmal ganz persönlich darauf
geblickt sowohl was ihre konstitution
angeht mit mitte 30 als auch die der
bundeskanzlerin die ja fast doppelt so
alt ist wie sie wie hält man das durch
was können sie dann persönlich aus
diesen langen verhandlungs nächten
schildern also zunächst einmal zu
deutschen kanzlerin
da wirklich viel geboten
18 8 mit einer losen souveränität mit
einer unglaublichen natürlich auch und
ist schon eine die stetig versucht
natürlich für ihre interessen für ihre
ideen zu kämpfen bei gleichzeitig in
brüssel den ganzen laden
zusammenzuhalten dass ich mich hier hoch
an
was uns betrifft haben wir nämlich ein
großes glück dass wir nicht alleine
waren bei diesen verhandlungen sagt dann
eben in dieser gruppe der sparsam
entwickelt als achte plant als kleines
österreich hat man kaum eine möglichkeit
der die eigenen interessen und die
eigenen gegen durchzusetzen dann müsste
ich in einer gruppe abstimmen
das hat gut funktioniert und so könnten
auch mit unseren beitrag leisten
ich glaube was jetzt die körperliche
konstitution betrifft das war für alle
ein stück herausfordern
das hat für danke lang gedauert letzten
beiden tage 60
also ich glaube es gibt da ein gleich
ganz egal wie alt man ist freuen uns
alle schon drauf wenn man sich dabei an
stunden am ordentlichen bett liegen das
thema rechtsstaatlichkeit war ganz
wichtig ist bei diesen verhandlungen und
das war eins was auf sie und die sparsam
vier ganz massiv in den vordergrund
gestellt haben hätten sie gedacht dass
sie mal eher auf eine allianz aus angela
merkel und viktor orban treffen wenn es
um das thema rechtsstaatlichkeit geht
das ist ja schon eine besondere
konstellation die sich da in den letzten
tagen ergeben hat naja ich glaube ganz
ganz so zuspitzen nicht das stinkt ist
es dort sehr stark objekt staatlichkeit
braucht haben und anderen seite und
irgendeine andere haben sie denn schafft
und patron versucht ja auch ein einsames
mister stand zu bringen und ich bin froh
dass dieser slogan ist angela merkel
kennt sie sind nun nur die recht stark
gemacht
letzte frage ist das jetzt üblich müssen
uns daran gewöhnen dass
rechtsstaatlichkeit die eigentlich
selbstverständlich sein sollte in diesem
europa in dieser eu dass sie jetzt so
verhandlungsmasse wird
nur zur verhandlungsmasse
rechtsstaatlichkeit
das ist die basis natürlich wird
diskussionen weiterhin geben wo die
rechtsstaat vereist und wo natürlich
wird weiter darüber diskussionen geben
welche instrumente nötig sind um das zu
messen und das wird auch weiter
diskussionen darüber geben was geschehen
soll wenn vielleicht das eine oder
andere land sich hier in die falsche
richtung entwickelt also ich glaube
diese debatte herr chefredakteur die
wird uns die nächsten jahre noch weiter
begleiten davon bin ich überzeugt ganz
unabhängig von diesem budget
verhandlungen
das war uns live und exklusiv
zugeschaltet aus wien der
österreichische bundeskanzler sebastian
kurz herzlichen dank und seine schönen
abend vielen dank herr chefredaktor und
alles lieber nach berlin